how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have really exciting news we
all suppose that we really weren't going
to see Ironman back in the MCU that
Robert Downey jr. was done with the
Ironman character he said after Avengers
in game he chose to stop playing the
character because it was time it was
time for him to move on but thanks to a
familiar face of the Grand Master Jeff
Goldblum of course we know that he is
indeed going to be returning to apprise
his role as Iron Man at least one more
time Jeff Goldblum recently did an
interview with BuzzFeed where he was
asked will we see Grandmaster return and
Thor love and thunder and in the
interview he said well hey while we're
talking about it I really hope so
I love Taika Waititi he's a really good
friend of mine but I played the role
again a couple of days ago I went to
Disney Studios and I recorded the
grandmasters voice for an episode of a
show that is going to be on Disney Plus
called what-if where it's an animated
version of all of the characters that we
know in love with Marvel and this
episode included the Grand Master and
Iron Man so Robert Downey jr. will do a
voice in that this episode included the
Grand Master and Iron Man so Robert
Downey will do a voice in that so this
was actually a pretty big debate for a
long time after Avengers endgame once we
found out about the Marvel series
what-if coming to Disney Plus there was
talk of a lot of characters returning to
do the voiceovers for their characters
for Disney Plus but with only a limited
number of episodes for Marvel's what-if
series come in and no talk of Robert
Downey jr. coming back to play Ironman
we were all beginning to wonder if he
was indeed ever going to be in the MCU
again even if it was as a voiceover role
for his character
Ironman but as you just heard Jeff
Goldblum it is official Robert Downey
jr. is going to return to reprise his
role as Iron Man in the upcoming Disney
Plus show Marvel's what-if and we
recently got a teaser trailer for
Marvel's what-if on the Disney Plus
video expanding the universe they showed
a lot of different scenarios for
Marvel's what-if including zombie
Captain America Peggy Carter as the one
who got the Super Soldier Serum Black
Panther as star-lord and other awesome
exciting things and Kevin Feige even
talked about what the show really is
going to be himself he said that in
marvel
what if the 23 movies of the MCU are
going to showcase one difference so what
if one thing was different in these
stories of these characters in the 23
MCU films for example one of them is
going to be what if instead of Steve
Rogers getting the Super Soldier Serum
Peggy Carter got it another one that we
saw was what if Steve Rogers was Iron
Man and not Tony Stark and as far as
Tony Stark is concerned we actually
haven't heard anything about what his
difference and his movies would be
there's been no footage of it because
again we weren't really sure if he was
going to be coming back to her prices
role but fortunately for us Jeff
Goldblum confirmed this by saying in his
what-if episode Tony Stark is in it
which means that Robert Downey jr. isn't
it Andy mentioned him by name and this
is actually quite interesting because
the Grandmaster and Tony Stark have
really nothing to do with each other
the Grandmaster the last time we saw him
was on Sekar and the last people that he
dealt with was Thor Valkyrie and Bruce
Banner so perhaps they could do
something along the lines of what if
instead of it being Bruce Banner it was
Tony Stark after all they're both
geniuses they're not too different than
the science Pres we're not sure what
it's going to be but I would love to see
the Grandmaster and Tony Stark together
I think that would be an awesome
conversation very sarcastic very woody
and probably very funny but Robert
Downey jr. is going to be returning one
more time to the MCU to play Tony Stark
/ iron man very exciting news even if it
is just in Marvel's what if we get to
see him one last time also don't forget
to subscribe to my channel for your
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 all
you have to do is be subscribed with the
notifications turned on like this video
and comment below so you can enter as
always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff